- people are 16 Commons apart on a
straight road so the first thing I'm
gonna do being that there's a lot of
like this person's here and this press
is there I want to try and represent
this with a diagram doesn't have to be
beautiful but at least I can sort of see
what's going on you'll see them in how
important this is so I'm gonna draw
here's my road okay
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
draw in two colors yeah so I'm gonna do
I'm actually you'll see why in a second
but I'm not gonna go all the way to the
end I'm gonna say okay let's put the
slow person in like here and I'm gonna
I'm gonna label them the slow person you
might wonder how did I know there's
going to be a slow person in a fast
person it's because for the next part of
the question when they're walking the
same direction they meet so I'm gonna
talk about that in a minute so here's a
fast person here's a slow person right
and we said they are what we say sick
think home is apart so I'm just gonna
put that distance in there okay now they
walk toward each other and then they
meet at some point now because I've got
one of them walking slower they're not
gonna move meet halfway right they're
gonna meet sort of closer to this end
yeah so I'm gonna do something like this
walks like so and then the other guy
because they're faster makes it sort of
past halfway yeah so this is the picture
of what's going on let's keep reading it
says they start walking at the same time
if they walk toward each other they will
meet in two hours okay so at this point
I want to put some information on to you
but I need to arm I need to start
introducing some pruning rules and
that's what we're gonna solve for right
so I'm gonna say let the first person
let's have them walk at a particular
speed and because it's fast let's say F
for fast at F kilometers per hour okay
that's their speed which is unknown at
the minute and then of course we've got
a slow person and I guess because I'm
very original I'm gonna say they walk at
s covetous per hour s for slow okay now
because in this situation I know they
walk for two hours right if the first
person was walking for one hour how far
how far would he walk and the answer is
he'd go F kilometers in a single hour if
I ask you how far he went in ten hours
if was walking that long it would be
naught F kilometers but ten F kilometers
if he could walk it like five colors per
hour ten times five was 50 right but I
don't know what F is if he's walking for
two hours how far does he walk well I
don't know how fast he's walking yet
right - f yeah so that's how far this
distance is right it's got for two hours
in exactly the same way this slow guy
right he walks two s right good now from
this I could already write down one of
my equations right if this length here
is 2's this one's 2f they add together
to cover the total distance yeah very
good
so what equation can we write for this
perfect excellent so there's our first
equation yeah and I'm going to give that
name it's not enough information on its
own and that's why they give us this
other piece of information so let's keep
reading it says if they walk in the same
direction so the distance between them
is decreasing so I'm going to draw
another road now okay so here's my road
again excuse me they're gonna start at
the same spot there's the slow one and
there's the fast one but now yeah it's
going this way this guy's going to get
away but the fast ones got to chase them
down right yeah exactly to catch up is
exactly right now the question says they
will meet in eight hours right so
obviously he's gonna walk further than
this right so it's not to scale but I'm
just gonna draw so this long line okay
let's suppose that's eight hours how far
is the slow person walk in that time
this was two hours gave us two ish so
it's 8 s very good you call that a s
right now how far does the fast person
walk well they're gonna walk all this
way and eventually catch up and that's
the meeting point is that okay so I've
got a meeting point here in the middle
and then I've got a meeting point over
here on the side the fast person's been
walking for the exact same amount of
time so how far they walked H and F very
good it's a longer distance because F is
bigger than s it's faster right okay now
this diagram here
also gives us another equation but it's
a bit trickier to see right
what we want is two things like this and
this which are equal to each other and
when you have a look at this diagram
what parts of this are equal to each
other
well see the 16 kilometers right it
corresponds to this distance here
that's right 16 colors and in this
distance as well that's how far the
first person walks but they mean the
same spot so do you agree that this red
line is the same as the black and the
blue lines together are combined so what
equation can I write that that captures
that what's the red line that's fade out
what's that equal to
bingo and that is a second equation from
a second piece of information okay now
from here I can actually make both of
these equations a bit simpler and then I
think you'll be able to sort of take it
from here right on this first equation
right do you see a common factor I can
divide everything through by that would
make it simpler to so that leaves me
with F plus s that's weight divided by 2
is 8
very good so I'll just call that one a
because that's where I got it from this
one here I've got a different common
factor what yeah yeah you divided
through everything by 8 which gives you
the 2 plus the S I'll call this new vein
and so you can see here there's a lot of
things you could do but it looks like I
can substitute this straight into here
you okay with that because that F I
could put here so I'm gonna even write
that I'm gonna substitute to a into 1 a
Saeta right so let's see instead of
writing F up here I'm gonna write 2 plus
s plus s right there yeah
so I'm gonna have 2 plus s plus s is
that ok that's equal 8 we're good
we can we can expand this right well we
can collect like terms rather we could
say 2 plus how many S's xu s subtract 3
from both sides
very good and so now I'm I'm sort of
their anti okay so this is apparently
this is the speed of the slow person
right yes if that's three what would you
if you look at the question like this
what F or this one even F is going to be
two plus the slow person's speed which
is five right so therefore F equals five
and you could check it out right in two
hours
how far will the fast person go
according to this ten kilometers and the
slow one will go six and same deal here
eight would mean the slope s would
travel 24 kilometres the fires person
has to cover this 16 and the 24 which is
eight times five that's 40 there's the
16 to 24 okay so as we sort of mentioned
this morning right the hard part of this
is not really the algebra part that part
just kind of falls out yeah it's like
it's like working out from here from the
words how do I then come up with two
equations and then you're right to go
it's worth pointing out and we did this
by substitution it's just as easy to do
it by elimination they kind of parallel
tools so for example see this guy here I
could have written this as F take away s
equals 2 and you can see I can add this
equation to this equation do you see
that that would eliminate the the minus
s and the plus s would just cancel so I
would to F equals 10 and I get the same
thing that I am got before okay so yeah
and it's worth saying as well even if
you don't construct the right equation
if you construct a pair of equations and
you start working with them you can
still demonstrate some of the
understanding we're looking for so you
wouldn't get 0 okay